if beauty is objective and necessary for  the flourishing of a society how do you  resolve disputes over whether a thing or  a person is beautiful and what criteria  makes something beautiful that doesn't  rely on subjective feelings well I would  I would defer to my friend Justice  Potter Stewart of course who is  frequently invoked in debates over  pornography and he's usually mocked  though he made a really great Point  Justice Stewart was asked to Define  obscenity and he said I can't quite  Define it but I know it when I see it  he's obviously right we all do know it  when we see it it's not actually that  hard to uh to discern these things